hi welcome my name is John Bodnar I'm a
tech fellow here at Capital One and I'm
not a data scientist but I am someone
who's working life is surrounded with
data and his job includes helping data
scientist at Capital One get their
models to production and this helps us
deliver better products for our
customers and those models are really an
important part of Capital One's products
and tools they give us the ability to
accurately predict who's going to pay us
back so in effect my paycheck depends on
data science please keep up the good
work I'm interested in how to improve
that good work today I'm going to talk
about how we all fall into the traps
that get science wrong and give some
ideas that may not get it quite perfect
but at least make things better so
people are if nothing else pattern
matters and storytellers you give us a
sky filled with stars and we make shapes
out of them and we create stories to
explain how they got there and this is
good discovering patterns is how we
learn and stories or how we share what
we've learned and the history of science
is really the history of our progress at
finding new patterns that better explain
the world around us and while the
history of science is filled with
individuals who suddenly notice
something that nobody ever saw before
this has become rarer over time science
today no matter what the field is mostly
data science experiments generate
tremendous amounts of data often using
sensors that detect information that's
invisible to human senses and were
utterly reliant on computers to collect
this data and to analyze it and data
scientist provide the tools and
expertise to process that data to find
the signal to tell the story to share
the findings it's a pretty powerful
position the modern world depends on it
completely and not just in science but
in every line of business from banking
to bus routes and if there's a lot of
information and then read to make sense
of it data science is there and there
are many examples of how data science
improves our lives but here are just a
few I'll start with my employer so back
when capital one was founded we use an
information based strategy to get the
right products the right customers and
today we now depend on open source data
technology is the process even more
information even quicker and this gives
us more insights for our businesses and
better meets customer needs and once you
have credit you can use it to buy stuff
and data science helps here to Amazon
uses data science to optimize every part
of its supply and delivery chain they've
even filed for a patent method and
system for anticipatory package
shipping's this is kind of cool they
ship a package to a geographic region
based on some data science analysis to
show that someone in that region will
want that package and then while on the
fly when someone actually does order
that package they change the shipping
label to actually go to that person so
after you've patented one-click shipping
all that's left really is just no click
shipping and now for something a little
bit more serious figuring out how to use
medicines more effectively so tamoxifen
is a drug that treat breast cancer and
it's well known that in some people
taking tamoxifen will print recurrences
but in other people it doesn't seem to
have an effect and it seems to come down
to one particular gene cyp2d6 and some
scientists the Mayo Clinic went back
over studies that had analyzed the
effect of this gene on people taking
tamoxifen and they figured out that some
studies had used tumor tissue to the
analysis and some studies had used
healthy tissue and it turns out that if
you look at the healthy tissue it gives
a much better indication of whether or
not the drug is effective so this is
great news because it means even more
people are going to benefit from
tamoxifen than people thought before and
there's actually some late-breaking
cancer news I couldn't fit onto a slide
microsoft announced a couple of weeks
ago that they think they can cure cancer
in the next ten years by using analyzing
data using the AI techniques they've
developed overtime and this sounds a
little optimistic but it's really
impressive the confidence in the power
of data science right and all of this is
great stuff data scientists look at
patterns and figure out ways to improve
our world but our need to see patterns
and tell stories can lead us astray once
upon a time priests would examine n
trail to figure out the secrets of the
universe and I'm not really sure how
they decided the insides of a sheep
where the answer to everything but i'm
sure that into any kind of rigorous
statistical analysis on that and maybe
some data scientists could have saved a
whole bunch of livestock
but then again maybe not because
sometimes despite the best of our
intentions the data analysis confuses
noise for signal and the results are
wrong and the science is wrong and it's
not we expected so how common is this
problem it's actually worse than you
think and I started thinking about this
presentation when I read an article in
The Economist and anyone at the keynote
this morning has probably already heard
this so you're familiar with fMRI is
they like you view a picture what goes
on inside your brain when you're
thinking about things and I could be
like reading Jane Austen or watching a
scary movie and over 40,000 studies have
been done with FM our eyes and anderzel
cone that link open university in sweden
had an idea he downloaded the control
data from a bunch of these studies and
split it up into 3 million different
random groupings and then pushed it
through the same software that people
use to analyze fMRI data and this is the
control data so there's absolutely no
pattern and it's across multiple studies
and so given this you'd expect about a
five percent p-value 0.05 so it's like
five percent of time to find a match
unfortunately seventy percent of the
time it found a match so the software
kept on finding patterns were absolutely
nothing existed and here's the scary
quote from the article after crunching
the numbers we think that around 3,000
studies can be effected without
revisiting each and every study it's
impossible to know which the 3,000 are
so the software that used to analyze
fMRIs is questionable what else has
problems psychological studies seem to
have quite a few problems there was an
article called estimating the
reproducibility of psychological science
it was published by Brian no sec from
UVA in science in August 2015 and dr.
nosik and 270 co-authors tried to
reproduce a hundred different psychology
studies turned out thirty-six percent
could actually be reproduced and his
conclusion about why it was so hard to
reproduce there are three possible
reasons for the results the original
effect was a false positive his
reproduction was a false negative or
both the original and replication
results are accurate but the experiment
methodology differed in significant ways
and this is really bad because if you
can't replicate the research because you
can't follow the steps
to generate and analyze it the papers of
little value because you don't know
whether the reason for the effect lied
lied in those steps it's another case we
just can't tell that signal from the
noise but psychology is a hard to
measure field right maybe there's better
luck when you deal with a more solid
branch of medical science like oncology
unfortunately there isn't see Glenn
Begley and Li L is published a letter to
nature in 2012 titled drug development
raised standards for preclinical cancer
research in it the report of the Amgen
big biotech company they tried to
replicate 53 landmark cancer studies
just six eleven percent of the studies
are reproducible and again the process
seemed to be a problem dr. Begley said
for results that could not be reproduced
data were not routinely analyzed by
investigators blinded to experimental
versus control groups they sometimes
said they presented specific experiments
that supported their underlying
hypothesis but that were not reflective
of the entire data set there are no
guidelines that require all datasets to
be reported in a paper often original
data are removed during the peer review
and publication process so yet again
missing steps and now missing data make
it impossible to replicate the results
and what's surprising is that all of
these problems were predicted in a paper
in 2005 by mathematician and medical
doctor johnny unitas in why most
published research findings are false he
described mathematical models that
predict the kind of results are
published or was certainly the kind of
results that are false and this all
sounds pretty bad right and it might
seem like I'm picking on academics what
about corporate data science ironically
I mentioned the problems in academic
medical research because they're the
ones doing the best job at uncovering
problems and exposing this if they're
almost certainly problems inside of
corporations too it's just that no one's
looking for them if a company has
problems the research and effects of
internal system no one might ever notice
and if someone does notice they're not
likely to tell the entire world that
something wasn't actually working
correctly so if you're doing data
science for an internal system that's
never going to go public you need to be
extra careful because there are fewer
people watching your work and
anyway everyone here probably heard of
this problem before and it has a name
it's a reproducibility crisis and there
are lots of reasons for this some of
them are cultural publisher parish has
encouraged people to try these
astonishing results that may not
actually be supported by the data and
journals they don't want to publish
papers that say I did an experiment and
found nothing and they don't republished
they don't publish papers and say I
tried someone else the experiment that
it was great so there's this is kind of
a problem and there are people who are
willing to commit fraud to advance their
careers and these are really tough
issues I don't have any good answers for
those and other things I don't have
answers for is problems with lab process
or data collection as some of these
papers mentioned some of these problems
are processed based and I'm assuming
everyone here is doing their best and
gather accurate data by following
standard practices because if the data
is incorrect isn't elected correctly
there's nothing they can be done
afterwards to make it better and I'm
sure you've all heard the term for this
garbage in garbage out so if you work it
luckily if we're going to data from
corporate systems this isn't as likely
to be a problem because you can extract
it from a database as the sampling isn't
an issue so the things that I'm talking
about today are what happens next doing
the right thing after acquisition the
data processing needs to be as rigorous
as the data collection was and I was
thinking about these problems with
reproducibility and data science and I
realize I've been dealing with my own
version of my entire career I think the
first five words every software
developer learns is it works on my
machine it works on my machine much my
career has been spent either trying to
get my code running in production the
same way it ran when I wrote it or
looking at someone else's code and
wondering why it wasn't working and the
answer is always the same works on my
machine and the software engineering
community knows this is a problem and
we've spent the last several decades
trying to solve it and we certainly have
not found a complete solution yet but
what's interesting is that we've gotten
better added recently and we're
developing tools and techniques that
make it easier to write code that
functions the same while you're
developing it as when it's running in
production and I thought about these
tools and techniques we've been using in
software engineering and realize that
while
exactly a one-to-one correspondence
between the problems of data scientists
and researchers and those of software
developers there are some similarities
and I bet some of these tools would
actually help so the first of these
tools is version control it wasn't so
long ago that most developers would
track changes in their code by copying
two different directories on their
computer and if they are really advanced
they'd copy it to a server or shared
disk and when someone new joined the
team you just say go to the shared disk
copy it down and hopefully it's up to
date and if to developers touch the code
of the same time the same code you spend
days like untangling the dependencies
you just put together so today software
developers we mostly use version control
systems like get to manage our software
and most data scientists are probably
doing something similar for their
scripts and programs how many people
here using git or subversion or
something else to manage things great
that's awesome that's what I expect but
so when I describe those bad old days of
software management it sounds absurd
right how can you release code we can't
even find it in the first place but many
data scientists and researchers are
still doing similar things when it comes
to their data even if you start from
that known good source that derived data
isn't tracked very well and if you lose
those intermediate transformations if
you can't share that data easily with
other people reproducing your results
becomes very difficult and unfortunately
is nothing like get or github for data
nothing that that's that popular but how
do they data this handle is going to
vary from field to field and it's based
on the volume in the sensitivity of the
data people here doing bio or chem
research you have electronic lab
notebooks and lab information management
systems and scientific data management
systems and all of these help keep track
of that initial data collection and
manage the equipment in your lab but
only a few of these things will provide
solutions for versioning the data after
you've collected and got to the
transformations if you're doing
large-scale physics like the Large
Hadron Collider those are producing so
much data they actually have to build
custom systems to handle it all and
actually get presentations and what
worked and those of us who are doing a
commercial work commercial companies
they can extract that data from
production systems and they can test new
data models
of it but those extracts are often not
really managed at all but this is not an
impossible problem your processing
should be repeatable given the same
initial data you should end up with the
same end results if you can store that
initial data somewhere the processing
steps that are taken by your programs
your results should be consistent so in
order to make sure when we're developing
software that the prof software builds
consistently from machine to machine
developers use build scripts that
describe the steps and data scientist
need is something similar to a build
script to exactly describe the
transformations that are performed when
going from that initial data to the
final result but if you're not managing
that initial data you're going to have a
problem and there are some startups that
are trying to provide tools in this
space and each one trying to solve some
different part of the problem there's
the node 0 Domino data sense plot lee
mode alpine data just to name a few none
of them have dominant market share yet
so it's hard to place your choice is
what you want to stick with but if you
have a company that's using get you can
try doing this it has large file storage
that you can enable and then the initial
set of data you can check it into your
repository and now your data is in a
distributed repository with a signature
to indicate it hasn't been modified as
marked with who check the data in and
when and if you want two experiments
against that data you can just create a
branch and you can apply your
transformations and you can check in the
transform data with you have the new
data checked in with a comment that
describes what transformations you did
and each step along the transformations
is another check-in and if it leads to a
dead end that's okay delete the branch
and you still have the initial data is
still there checked in safe and secure
or if you have two branches of data you
want to compare the results from that
you can do that as well and see how
different sets of transformations took
you to different places and once the
code in the data are tracked in
repositories it becomes easier to review
and science has been doing this for a
long time it's the peer review process
that papers go through before
publication and software engineers have
adopted the peer-review concept into the
code review concept but there are
differences between peer review and code
review code of view happens in small
chunks one bug fix or feature edition at
a time
and we don't wait until the very end
because it's too hard look an entire
program and understand what's going on
peer review in science it normally
happens right before publication and
it's difficult at that point for someone
else to get a deep understanding of all
the steps that were taken and especially
if the data and the tools aren't
available so the people analyzing you're
doing the peer review can't actually
understand what all the steps were in
between but to be honest reviewing
everything is opinion and code review
doesn't actually find everything and
it's not always clear just when looking
at code if something works correctly and
because of this software engineering
teams usually have testers who write
test scripts and manually interact with
the application they click through the
UI is then commands to the servers they
try to validate the things that we're
working before you do to work as
expected and unexpected input doesn't
lead to strange bugs and crashes but the
problem of doing this by hand is that
people are terrible at boring repetitive
tasks like clicking through you I the
same way every single time someone
checks in a change luckily computers
don't get forward in fact the Excel of
those kind of repetitive tasks that
people hate to do and so test automation
has become common with software
engineers we write unit tests that
validate that the functions we write
given certain initial data and produce
the exact same output and then we stitch
together our tests and create
integration tests that to check all
modules across each other and the best
thing about this is that all of these
tests get run automatically every time
you build the software all that boring
work goes away and data science could
benefit from automated test harnesses to
at the very least that build script I
mentioned you want to run it through and
make sure you can consistently go from
that initial data to your final output
if you can't is either a bug in your
build script or there's a bug in your
tools and if you're able to keep those
intermediate stages of data in some
super positive then you can test
individual transformations to make sure
the results make sense in effect you've
created unit tests for data science and
in order to simplify automated testing
you need to have a defined interface
that can be automatically called so for
data scientists this is going to mean
defining a standard specification for
what data looks like and how tools are
run and I understand software engineers
be a little too fond of specifications
but we keep going back to them because
they give us a good trade-off between
solving exactly the problem we have for
one particular situation and creating
something that other people can
understand what we're doing and it can
reuse what we've done and sometimes
using it in ways we never thought of in
the first place and the more the
datasets are organized according to
standards more easily tools can be
written to work with those data sets and
the easier becomes our automated test
against the data that comes out to see
there's any obvious problems with your
data and this is a two-way street the
more the tools are written to expect
certain data formats the more easily
tools can be shared evaluated repurposed
and the easier becomes to check for
errors by writing automated tests that
run new and modified tools against known
good data to see if the results are
improved if there's actually a mistake
and the kind of test that can be written
are limited by imagination has anyone
heard of fuzzing all right so this is
what fuzzing is every so often you'll
hear a hacking attack in the news where
someone put an invalid image into an ad
network and then someone goes in their
browser and they visit a web page and it
downloads this image and attacks your
computer opens up a backdoor and this is
a really terrible thing to have happen
so what software engineers do to find
these kinds of problems is the right
tools called fuzzes that just send
garbage data into functions to see what
comes out and hopefully the function
will see its garbage data just reject it
and sometimes it crashes in weird ways
and if you're really unlucky it exposes
the security hole and the programs and
scripts that are used by data scientists
really should be fuzzed once you have
these standard inputs and outputs
defined if a winner eight standard
programs to send an unexpected data and
hopefully you won't crash but more
importantly garbage data won't lead to
meaningful results and that fMRI
software i mentioned earlier that's
exactly what happened no one ever tried
it with bad data before and if someone
had actually tried bad data earlier that
problem at haven't found sooner and
40,000 more papers might be considered
valid so setting up standards inside of
your organization is really just the
beginning
if standard data structures and standard
tool interfaces are defined for research
fields or industries you have standard
sets of tests and standard repositories
of known good data and a journals adopt
them papers and can adopt them any
submitted paper kind of its data and its
tools validated just as part of the
submission process as a reproducibility
stops being something that you consider
afterwards or great expense and little
interest instead of being a core part of
what it means to submit a paper so the
next tool is open source and the modern
software world is built on open source
even companies that use that rely on
closed source and selling programs they
still live on this foundation of freely
available software and all of this is
relatively new at the turn of the
century Microsoft CEO is comparing Linux
in the open source movement to communism
in cancer and today Microsoft's a number
one contributor on github so using code
that's open sourced means that you're
using code that's been reviewed by lots
of other people and it's code that you
can review yourself and open sourcing
your own code allows other people to
suggest improvements to your work and to
find bugs and things that you've done
and remember no matter how many smart
people are in your organization's and
all of us work an organization with lots
of smart people there's always more
smart people outside than inside and
using open source that you take
advantage of all those people and for
data scientist using open source falls
into two categories and the first is
something probably everyone here is
already doing don't write tools from
scratch we can find a well vetted
open-source tool that does what you need
all right everyone here is doing that
right yeah okay and if you can't find
exactly what you need try to start from
something existing an open source and
modify it and if you really really can't
find anything if your work from scratch
try to open source what you produce you
might think it's unimportant or trivial
to solve one small problem but you might
have the solution to somebody else's
concerns so secondly using open source
means open sourcing those datasets and
their history of transformations I do
realize just as companies can't open
source all their software no one's gonna
open source all of their data trivial
examples if you have stuff that
private information in it it's going to
have to be anonymised first you can't
release things that are inviolate
people's privacy and no company is going
to release data that it considers a
competitive advantage that's just a
given right but it's probably more that
can be open source than you realize any
software or data that's used for
published papers really it should be
made as much available as is legally
possible so your work can be replicated
by anyone not just people who are doing
that peer review in the first place and
people have been think about how to
integrate open source with papers for a
while now and there are some interesting
solutions out there you can use your
digital object identifier to do is to
refer back to your code we reference it
in a paper and if you've released code
on your scripts on github zone odo
actually has the ability to integrate
with github and generate do is for you
off of your codes you can then cite them
and one last thought just as open source
tools can be used by other people in
ways their creators never expected open
source data can then be reanalyzed but
other people and discover things the
original creator of the data never
expected and this is kind of important
so what about those cases where you
can't release your data and your
publicly in your tools publicly there's
still value in inter sourcing and Inter
sourcing is a lot like what it sounds
like you take the tools that people use
in the open source community like open
repositories and blogs and forums and
you just keep them inside that corporate
firewall it's very helpful and its many
the same benefits as open source is just
a much smaller scale alright so this
lets you break down silos inside of your
company people can expose their data and
their tools to other people inside you
can start conversations going and people
outside of your immediate team can reuse
and retest your work so in corporations
another idea when you have that
corporate data source that everyone's
pulling data from try to set up a
service that wraps it and this way this
one service and do the anonymization of
that data and store it on a server and
slice it up by date or line of business
whatever makes sense for you and as you
defined a standard format for this data
everyone can share it there's no more
that's hiding data and random
directories on your computer and go back
to a single known good source as a place
to work from and
talk about open source and its practices
it's hard to believe that open source
was actually once considered a fad but
another way it's kind of understandable
because software developers we go
through a whole bunches of fads we
chased it all the time and for every
good one that comes along like open
source we have bad ones like enterprise
javabeans of anyone had to deal with
those once upon a time so there is a
reason though why we do this while we
move from one tool to another and that's
because the world of technology changes
so quickly and as things change
different approaches make more sense so
20 years ago when networks were slow and
servers were really expensive we would
build giant monolithic apps that ran on
one big server and now servers are
cheaper networks are fast so what we do
is with lots of little servers all work
together and they spin up and down based
on demand and all runs in virtual
machines and this is a better way to
solve the problem and it will be good
for research papers take advantage of
modern tools also many people still
write using tech and la tech and they
publish in PDF and HTML but there have
been some experiments with new
technologies from 2008 to 2011 the
optical society of america and the
National Library of Medicine they
published 38 papers using truly
interactive science publishing that's
actually what they call this technique
the papers were included interactive
diagrams that and data that are viewable
using browser plugins and desktop
software and in 2015 dr. Michael
Ackerman published the results of the
experiment and it was a qualified
success what he said was truly
interactive science publishing was shown
to have enough educational value that
readers were willing to invest in the
needed setup in learning phases and the
social aspects of data sharing and the
enlarged review process maybe the
hardest obstacles to overcome so there
are two things that are interesting
about this first working on better data
sharing and better review process is
essential it always keeps on coming back
to this and secondly you have to be
careful when you pick your tools browser
plug-ins and desktop software sounded
great in 2008 in 2016 it sounds like
another fad like it or not PDF and HTML
they've stood the test of time and
anything that replaces or supplements
them needs to be chosen very wisely but
this experiment really should continue
until the right slide great they're
interactive tools that have been proven
if you're using Python I assume a lot of
people here using Python why not embed a
notebook and this way people can see the
code in the data in Iraq they can see
the graphs being generated in real time
right on the spot and they can play with
the numbers and see what happened if
you're doing it analysis in Excel why
not publish your Excel files and the
idea is not just interaction for
interactions sake it's make concepts
that are difficult more accessible to
everyone even to experts right and the
people like more people I can understand
your paper the more people can learn
from and verify your work the harder it
becomes to hide dubious results and this
only improves reproducibility so these
are the steps that software developers
try to follow you version build script
review you run automated positive and
negative tests stick to standards open
source what you can use open source when
you can open source what you can take
advantage of modern technologies it's
not a perfect process but it has within
it the checks and balances that have
improved the quality of software over
the last decade and the nice thing about
this is that this is a gradual chain of
improvements you have to do all of these
things all at once start versioning your
tools and your data and get people
reviewing your code and sharing fixes
and start sharing that code and data and
public repositories as much as possible
start experimenting with new ways to
release your data so that's easier to
understand and some of these things
could be done today others are going to
require the creation and adoption of new
tools and the hardest changes are the
ones that require the group action and
improvements to existing processes it's
not going to be easy but this is all
really important so over 30 years ago
Fred Brooks wrote that there's no silver
bullet that will solve all problems in
software development and there is
nothing that's going to perfect data
science either but adopting these tools
and techniques that software engineers
have been using can reduce the problems
with reproducibility that play
data science and help us find better
medical treatments and make companies
more efficient and make the world a
better place so thank you for your time
hope you found these ideas and
approaches useful I wanted to thank
Andrew sheckman rook Jackie castle and
Jeannie Drury for their feedback they
helped me to understand some of the
problems facing data science and any
remaining mistakes they're entirely mine
so any questions sure as a note oh yeah
so if you have your coding github
already you can use the notes Enota can
then link with your github account than
generated and our archive it for you
could a DIY of your code so you can cite
it yeah anything else oh sure it depends
i mean so for example like going back to
software if it's images you can sit
there just like if a jpeg or gif or PNG
has generate some that has like a PNG or
gif header just I call function and see
what happens and see what see what
breaks and this goes back to defining
standards when your data is when your
tools expect data on certain formats you
need to me if you can standardize that
the more we can standardize everything
the simpler become to build tools that
can be shared because a jiff is the jif
as a jiff hasn't changed in 30 years but
if every ever there are some places with
our some standards understand in
research but there are few and far
between where people in industry have
decided this is how all data must look
and all tools must expect data in this
way and you can build things ad-hoc for
yourself or your own programs and try it
out but the more you can share them and
where you can have a standardized easier
it becomes there's bills on top of
itself yes yes yes oh absolutely right
as long as you're that p value of 0.05
that you want to sit there and beat then
one in 20 times it's going to come up
good right so you have to be careful
about that and recognize this and this
is this is I didn't want to talk much
about data collection and and the
submission process but people do find
that bad habit when the experiment ten
times it worked once so submit it and
clearly the other nine times had some
signal here about this may not be the
best solution but once you hit the
results would you actually submit and
that's what dr. Unity's was talking
about weed into publication that people
submit the good stuff and leave behind
all the bad stuff so good point anything
else
first of all sounds like a great talk
like how do I hide my mistakes may
remember that for later so this is where
things like get actually come in handy
so databases or an interesting case I
want to get to software engineering on
this people now will start doing
migrations of their database and
described in a little text files
describe exactly how the database change
revision to revision and those get
checked in and run by tools that way you
know exactly what happened and when
people who hack the database directly
make changes that's bad you shouldn't do
that and the same thing applies to code
having get that does a signature on your
code every single time really does help
because you can't probably
mathematically can beat the sha-1
practically you can't so you know that
no one's actually modify whatever
they've checked in is what if actually
happened we have automated systems that
run these things for you automatically
when the deployments aren't done by hand
when it's always a tool doing it for you
this is actually have been working with
data scientists at Capital One is doing
see I CD in place the continuous
integration canoeist delivery in place
then a person can't sneak something in
it went through the whole process and
everything was being pulled from
computers along the way so if someone
did something bad you can look back at
the history and say oh that's the bad
thing and this is the person to the bad
thing it really comes down to just
getting those processes in place to keep
it and keep everything tracked let that
answer your question okay anyone else
sure
asking in relation to not so much the
same academic space but let's say
capital one if you have to report your
findings to a regulator and have to be
able to reproduce and understand it how
did any experience with that and try to
get third parties you were posted for
regulating organizations so this is the
citizen too dangerous ground for me so
to answer to this one I don't have any
personal experience with it and if I did
I couldn't tell you about it so but this
is a case I'd want use capital on it but
any company that has people have to look
at their internal systems analyze what
they're doing you want to make sure it's
repeatable and understandable and I I
can't answer anything for capital one so
yes sorry anyone else great everyone
gets go to lunch a few minutes early
thank you for your time